es ist Fabi jemanden der die Ziegen
angegriffen hat und da ganz schlimme
Sachen gemacht hat wo ich einfach nur
noch wochenlang heulend auf dem Fußboden
gelegen habe die hat mir ganz viele
Fragen geschickt und um das Thema
Gemüsegarten selbst Versorgung um den
Hof den ich neu gekauft habe fangen wir
am besten gleich mal an ich kaufe
normalerweise wenn ich nicht gerade so
eine verrückte Challenge wie jetzt mache
wo ich nur noch selbst erzeugte
lebensmittelärzte für 100 Tage die
Challenge läuft gerade aber
normalerweise kaufe ich trotzdem relativ
normal ein also ich baue das Obst und
das Gemüse für meine Familie fast
komplett selber an außer wenn man
irgendwas komplett in die Hose geht es
wächst ja nicht jedes Gemüse jedes Jahr
gleich gut und manchmal haben wir auch
einen kompletten Ernteausfall dann gehe
ich natürlich in den Laden und kauft das
einfach zu aber sonst baue ich das Obst
und Gemüse komplett selber an wir haben
Hühner für Eier wir haben unser eigenes
Fleisch und normalerweise melke ich auch
Ziegen ich habe das letztens schon mal
erzählt ich habe im Moment keine Ziegen
mehr weil ich da alle Probleme hatte mit
in der die Ziegen angegriffen hat und da
ganz schlimme Sachen gemacht hat
deswegen habe ich im Moment keine Ziegen
mehr aber nächstes Jahr kommen wieder
neue wenn ich auf meinen Bauernhof
gezogen bin das hat sich viel an aber
ganz viele Sachen wie zum Beispiel
Getreide bauen wir quasi gar nicht
selber an und das macht ja wenn man
normal ist schon ein Großteil der
Ernährung aus genauso wie Öl genauso wie
Schokolade und andere Süßigkeiten kaufen
wir auch ganz normal ein wenn ich nicht
so verrückte Sachen mache wie im Moment
mit dieser Challenge man kann einen
Gemüsegarten auf die Art wie ich Beete
anlege rund ums Jahr anlegen also es ist
komplett egal wann ihr damit starten
wollt macht das einfach dann wenn es
euch am besten reinpasst wenn ihr jetzt
zum Beispiel im November zwei Wochen
Urlaub habt dann ist es vielleicht
sinnvoll dass da neu anzulegen ihr könnt
aber auch erst im Februar anfangen ihr
könnt immer ja anfangen das ist komplett
egal ich habe rund um das Thema Beete
anlegen und zum allerersten Mal Gemüse
anbauen oder eben eine neuen
Gemüsegarten anlegen einen komplett Mini
Kurs gefilmt mit drei Videos den
verlinke ich euch gerne mal hier unten
in der Videobeschreibung schaut da auf
jeden Fall gerne mal rein wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie ich die Beete anlege
die jahrelang nahezu unkrautfrei bleiben
und wo man auch viel Wasser speichert so
dass man im Sommer viel weniger gießen
muss super anfängerfreundlich mach das
mach das wenn ihr neue Beete anlegen
wollt dann so wenn Gurken bitte werden
dann liegt das allermeisten daran dass
sie irgendwie trockenheitsstress haben
und nicht ganz gleichmäßig mit Wasser
versorgt worden sind und ihr wisst wenn
ihr meine Videos schon länger verfolgt
dass ich in meinem Garten quasi gar
nicht gieße aber die eine große Ausnahme
das sind die Gurken und zwar genau
deswegen weil wenn man das nicht macht
wenn man die einfach so vor sich
hinwachsen lässt ohne regelmäßig zu
gießen dann werden die Gurken bitter und
bittere gurken sind auch giftig also
wenn eine Gurke bitter schmeckt wenn ihr
die abbeißt dann spuckt das auf jeden
Fall wieder aus weil das wirklich
gefährlich werden kann und achtet
einfach darauf dass wenn ihr Gießwasser
habt das vielleicht knapp ist dass ihr
das eher den Gurken gebt als dem anderen
Gemüse gibt es auf jeden Fall also ich
habe für quasi jedes Gemüse dass ich
anbaue so meine go to Sorten die ich
immer wieder anbaue weil die sich so gut
bewährt haben und ich habe auch schon in
ganz vielen Videos darüber gesprochen
ich habe für ich glaube jeden Monat ein
Aussaat Video gemacht wo ich immer
vorstelle was man gesät wird und welche
Sorten ich empfehlen würde das ändert
sich ja auch manchmal je nachdem was
gerade für eine Jahreszeit ist manche
karottensorten sehe ich nur ganz früh
oder ganz spät im Jahr und andere dann
eher im Sommer und auch mit dem Salat
ist das so wenn man im Sommer einen
anbaut der schoss fest ist dann geht der
Salat im Sommer nicht so schnell in die
Blüte und deswegen schaut euch gerne
immer zu dem Monat das passende Video an
ich verlinke euch die komplette Playlist
unten in der Videobeschreibung ich habe
aber auch noch eine andere Ankündigung
die euch vielleicht interessiert es wird
irgendwann im Laufe des nächsten Jahres
eine saatgut-abobox geben Sorten von mir
drin sind die ich selber absolut heiß
und innig Liebe so dass ihr jeden Monat
Saatgut zugeschickt bekommt dass dann in
dem Monat ausgesät wird da könnt ihr
euch auf jeden Fall schon mal darauf
freuen die Vorbereitungen laufen auf
Hochtouren ich kann aber noch nicht
sagen wann wir damit fertig sind und
wann wir los starten können aber das
kommt man sagt immer wenn jemand fragt
wie geht's dir sagt man immer
automatisch ja gut und dir aber manchmal
ist es eben nicht so und ich glaube
vielen geht's nicht immer gut also ich
hatte einen Burnout man sieht das oft
nach außen nicht wie viel Arbeit
Wurzelwerk macht also das ist mein
Vollzeitjob und auch schon seit einigen
Jahren und ich habe 12 Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter und das ist nicht nur
dieser YouTube Kanal sondern noch ganz
viel mehr also wir haben auch einen Blog
wir haben ganz viele andere Kanäle auf
anderen Plattformen und wir haben
Videokurse wo wir ganz viele Leute
durchs Gartenjahr begleiten und das ist
für die Arbeit alles zusammen die
letzten ja vier fünf Jahre war so eine
60 Stunden Woche für mich total normal
obwohl ich noch eine Familie habe und
auch mit meinem Sohn Zeit verbringen
möchte und es geht total vielen
Youtubern so und das tut mir auch total
gut mit Leuten zu sprechen denen das
auch so geht weil das ist so ein toller
Job den wir haben es ist so ich bin so
unfassbar dankbar dafür dass ich das
machen darf das ist ja nicht
selbstverständlich und trotzdem ganz zu
viel werden weil es niemanden gibt der
einem sagt so jetzt ist immer gut du
kannst immer noch so viel mehr geben und
es ist so schön für so eine schöne Sache
wie das noch mehr Leute rausgehen und
Gärten dann noch viel mehr zu geben und
trotzdem wenn ich an den Punkt gekommen
wo ich einfach nur noch wochenlang heult
auf dem Fußboden gelegen hat und es
nicht mehr hingekriegt habe ich
Spülmaschine einzuräumen weil ich das
nicht konnte ich konnte nichts machen
und das ist ja teilweise auch oder
überwiegend 7 Tage Woche sage
noch nicht mal an Weihnachten frei
gemacht und das ist halt schwierig dann
sich selber dann auch zu bremsen und
sagen okay ja jetzt jetzt mache ich mal
einen Tag frei oder zwei Tage frei weil
es immer ja was zu tun gibt das ist
glaube ich das schwierige dann zu sagen
hey jetzt mache ich mal wirklich jetzt
ein Tag frei und und dann geht mal Ruhe
ja das ist glaube ich das
Schwierigste an dieser oder so eine
selbständigen Arbeit auch in gewissen
und vor allem wenn man da emotional so
drinnen hängt auch wenn es ja dann ja
dein Kanal ist ein Block ist dann ja man
will immer das Beste sage ich mal ähm
zeigen oder oder oder einfach generell
einfach schöne Sachen zeigen und und ja
seinen Abonnenten immer einen tollen
Einblick zu geben und und Wissen zu
vermitteln und klar und das wieder auch
gesagt dass er fordert viel ja Arbeit
natürlich so und ich muss das jetzt
wirklich lernen auch mal was anderes zu
machen das hört sich so doof an aber ich
habe das total verlernt und einfach auch
mal zu sagen ich bin jetzt nicht fertig
geworden mit dieser und jeder Sache weil
es gibt immer irgendwas was nicht fertig
geworden ist und trotzdem mache ich
jetzt mal einfach ein ganz normales
Wochenende
wo ich nur am See rumhänge und mit
meinem Sohn Spiele und
ja mit Zeit für Freunde nehme ich merke
auch wie viel mehr Lust und Elan ich
habe wenn ich einfach mal was anderes
zwischendurch gemacht habe und ich muss
nur lernen dann kein schlechtes Gewissen
zu haben wenn ich was anderes mache ich
habe einen Bauernhof gekauft und das ist
schon immer mein Lebenstraum gewesen und
ja ich habe dazu schon ein ganzes Video
gemacht verlinke ich euch hier in der
Ecke und unten in der Videobeschreibung
und ich glaube das ist so die Frage die
am häufigsten gestellt wird was ist mit
deinem Bauernhof und wann gibt es
endlich News es gibt leider noch keine
News weil ich den Bauernhof zwar schon
gekauft habe aber ich muss vom Kauf an
anderthalb Jahre warten bis die Leute
die jetzt da wohnen ausziehen und ich
einziehen kann und bisher ja hat sich da
einfach noch gar nichts getan ich bin da
fast nie wenn schon bin ich da wenn ich
mal mit einem Handwerker durchgehe jetzt
nächste Woche ist einen Termin wo wir
überlegen wo eine Photovoltaikanlage auf
die scheunendächer kommen könnte ja also
da gibt es halt wirklich noch nicht viel
darüber zu erzählen ich bin unfassbar
aufgeregt ich denke ungefähr drei
Stunden am Tag nur über den Bauernhof
nach und was für Tiere ich dann haben
möchte und wie schön das wird alles am
Haus zu haben weil bisher wohne ich in
der Wohnung mitten in der Stadt und
nutzte für meine Selbstversorgung andere
Grundstücke die hier in der Umgebung
sind aber es ist halt immer weiter weg
ich muss immer alles hin und her
transportieren dann habe ich doch ein
Werkzeug zu Hause vergessen habe keinen
Korb im Garten um die Sachen nach Hause
zu tragen und das ist immer sehr viel
Kuddelmuddel und ich freue mich so so
doll darauf wenn ich endlich auf den
Bauernhof ziehen kann im Spätsommer 23
kann ich einziehen und vielleicht wenn
vorher schon irgendwas rund um den Hof
passiert kann ich schon mal die Kamera
mitnehmen aber im Moment gibt's da
einfach noch gar nichts zu zeigen oder
zu sagen oder zu sehen leider ich habe
auf jeden Fall schon Respekt davor weil
ich glaube ich kann mir noch gar nicht
vorstellen wie viel Arbeit das ist ein
eigenes Haus zu haben wo man für jeden
Balken und jeden Tag Ziegel auf einmal
selber verantwortlich ist mach ja schon
viele Gedanken ich ziehe zum Glück mit
meinem Freund ein also er wird auch
direkt dann da einziehen aber ich glaube
dass ich das absolut noch unterschätzte
das wird nicht so einfach werden aber
ich glaube trotzdem wunderschön
eine lustige Frage wie alt bist du und
mit wem ziehst du auf deinem neuen Hof
ein es ist Fabi
das Thema so wer mein Freund ist und
auch über meine Beziehung möchte ich
eigentlich gar nicht so viel Teilen ich
habe das letztes Jahr für mich
entschieden dass mir das lieber ist das
einfach privat zu halten nachdem z.B
Fabi und ich im Urlaub fotografiert
wurden es ist nicht jemand zu uns
gekommen und hat gesagt können wir ein
Foto zusammen machen also das ist ja
total in Ordnung sondern halt von weit
weg so hahaha ja genau
schon sehr sehr viel mit deinen
Abonnenten ich denke das ist in dem Fall
Sinn macht deine Privatleben auch
wirklich privat zu halten und das ist
auch für mich ein besseres Gefühl dass
einfach davor zu beschützen und das das
einfach nur meins ist sehr verständlich
dass die Leute auch
neugierig sind
bist du manchmal neugierig weil so
wenn du es nicht so genau weißt ich kann
es auf jeden Fall nachvollziehen dass
die Leute neugierig sind ja und und
dementsprechend natürlich auch in dieser
Thematik dann mehr wissen wollen
natürlich ist ja auch sehr spannend
den idealen beetpartnern da habe ich
eine Tabelle für euch die ihr euch
runterladen könnt und ausdrucken könnt
ich habe meine zum Beispiel in meinem
Gewächshaus immer griffbereit wenn ich
was aussehe und gucken will welche
Gemüse passen denn zusammen und welche
sollten eher nicht zusammenwachsen dann
hole ich mir die einfach raus und habe
die immer gleich griffbereit die
verlinke ich euch gerne unter dem Video
in der Videobeschreibung also ladet ihr
einfach runter und drückt die aus das
ist glaube ich am praktischsten weil man
kann sich das sowieso nicht alles
auswendig merken deswegen sind die
schlimmsten Tiere die man sich überhaupt
anschaffen kann aber macht es bitte
trotzdem weil sie sind einfach so
charmant und so süß und wickeln einen so
schnell um den Finger dass es trotzdem
wunderbar ist Ziegen zu halten aber
warum ich das sage das Ziegen
schrecklich sind ist das Ziegen sehr
gerne ausbrechen das heißt man braucht
einen sehr guten hohen Zaun vor allem
wenn man größere Rassen halten möchte
Zwergziegen sind da vielleicht noch ein
bisschen einfacher ich habe meine Ziegen
bisher meistens in Elektro du
scharfsnetzen gehalten und egal wie hoch
die sind wenn die raus wollen dann
kommen die da drüber zumindest ein zwei
von denen die besonders gut springen
können ansonsten sind Ziegen wunderbar
und ich vermisse es super arg dass ich
im Moment keine Ziegen mehr haben kann
ich werde direkt wenn ich auf den Hof
ziehe auf jeden Fall wieder Ziegen
anschaffen wenn ihr Ziegen halten
möchtet um die zu melken dann würde ich
entweder Thüringer waldziegen empfehlen
das ist eine robuste alte Rasse oder
angloopia die haben Schlappohren ich bin
ein größerer Freund von angeloubia
Ziegen ich werde mir auch nächstes Jahr
wieder welche anschaffen aber beide
Rassen sind super toll ich hatte auch
schon Toggenburger Ziegen auch eine ganz
ganz tolle Rasse ansonsten gibt's auch
noch Fleischrassen da hatte ich bisher
nur buchenziegen und das ist wirklich
die entspannteste Rasse die man halten
kann das sind richtig Liebe gutmütige
Ziegen auch mit Schlappohren super süße
Tiere die auch nicht so gerne über den
Sound springen und ähm die kann man auch
super gut halten wenn man zum Beispiel
benutzen zum Kuscheln haben will und es
gibt ganz viele ziegenböckchen die
verkauft werden die sonst geschlachtet
würden also wenn man nur Ziegen zum
Kuscheln haben möchte dann kann man
einfach ein paar kastrierte Böcke holen
die stinken dann auch nicht mehr die
sind auch meistens lieb also es ist
meistens bei Ziegen nicht so dass die
Böcke irgendwie großartig aggressiv sind
das Problem hat man bei Schafen viel
mehr aber wenn ihr die nur zu
Liebhaberei halten wollt dann holt euch
doch ein paar Böckchen dann kriegen die
noch ein schönes Zuhause und entgehen
vielleicht der Tiefkühltruhe zur Haltung
könnte ich auch ein ganzes halbstündiges
oder dreistündiges Video machen ich will
jetzt das Video hier nicht so sprengen
man braucht ungefähr 2000 Quadratmeter
Platz pro Ziege das wäre natürlich ideal
wenn man im Sommer kein Holz zu füttern
möchte Ziegen fressen viel mehr
gestritten wie Brombeeren oder Schlehen
oder schälen auch mal die Rinde von
jungen Bäumen ab als dass sie Gras
fressen also wenn man viel Gras hat
sollte man eher scharfe halten wenn man
viel Busch und gestritten hat dann eher
Ziegen ich habe meine Ziegen in einem
alten Pferdeanhänger gehalten damit ich
die Weide oft wechseln konnte das war
sozusagen deren Stall und deren
Transportmittel in einem weil ja wenn
man die Weide oft wechselt dann können
sich Parasiten nicht so an dem Ort
festsetzen und die Ziegen nehmen nicht
immer wieder die Eier die sie
ausscheiden wieder über das Futter auf
zu dem Thema zeitsparend und unkrautfrei
Gärtnern habe ich schon mal ein Video
gemacht das verlinke ich euch gerne da
drüben ansonsten geht raus und macht die
Welt ein bisschen grüner und wir sehen
uns im nächsten Video wieder bis dann
macht's gut tschüss